so our dogs are donated by a number of  breeders from working lines and we just  take a look at what the dog's natural  abilities are what their innate  strengths are we have law enforcement  dogs urban search and rescue we do some  imprinting with bomb detection some  early drug detection in fact our cancer  study was interrupted briefly so that  somebody could grab the pseudo cocaine  for that training we also do with a  medical alert so that's the diabetic  alert training and then the ovarian  cancer detection study that you observed  to appreciate how great these these dogs  noses are so if you and I can see 1/3 of  a mile jog can see 3,000 miles so that's  the difference between my ability to  smell in these dogs you can actually see  the behavioral changes when they catch  odor yes I am consistently amazed at  their ability to do this work  it's truly mark  you